La nuit où Clovis fut conçu, sa mère,
la reine Basine,
fit un songe qu'elle interpréta ainsi.
Elle allait mettre au monde un lion,
qui lui-même allait engendrer des loups.
Elle a ce rêve étrange.
Elle réveille son mari et lui dit :
"Regarde par la fenêtre
et dis moi ce que tu vois."
"Je viens de voir un lion et un centaure,
et tous les animaux sont autour
d'eux et semblent vraiment ravis."
Il se rendort, elle le reveille une
deuxième fois, elle dit :
"Va voir. Dis moi ce que tu vois."
"J'ai vu un léopard,
un ours et un chacal."
Et les animaux ont l'air inquiets.
Troisième stade du rêve :
"Dis-moi ce que tu vois par la fenêtre."
"J'ai vu des chiens, un chacal, un vautour,
et tous les animaux sont terrorisés.
C'est la panique la plus complète !"
Alors l'interprétation de ce rêve,
puisque Basine et Childéric,
vont donner le jour à Clovis qui
va devenir le roi des Francs.
Et sous le règne de Clovis,
le royaume se portera à merveille.
Mais ce rêve interprété veut
dire qu'avec les descendants,
et les héritiers de Clovis,
tout s'en ira à la dérive.
Les héritiers de Clovis
se sont effectivement entre déchirés,
durant tout le VIᵉ siècle.
Cette période a été rapidement
perçue par les contemporains,
comme la plus noire
de l'histoire de l'humanité.
Ne disait-on pas qu'après l'Empire
viendrait la fin du monde ?
La légende du rêve de la mère de Clovis,
est élaborée par la tradition
orale et transcrite,
pour la première fois
au milieu du VIIᵉ siècle,
par un auteur anonyme à qui on a donné
le nom de Frédégaire.
Frédégaire est un chroniqueur qui écrit
l'histoire des Francs dans les années 660.
C'est un homme qui réside sans doute
dans le royaume de Burgonde,
c'est à dire plutôt dans la région
orientale du monde Franc,
et qui a une attitude relativement
critique à l'égard de la royauté,
considérant qu'une royauté faible
et meilleure qu'une royauté forte,
telle qu'elle existait au VIᵉ siècle,
à l'époque de Clovis.
C'est Frédégaire qui relate aussi
la légende de Mérovée, grand père de Clovis,
qui a donné son nom
à la dynastie mérovingienne.
Les Mérovingiens doivent leur nom à Mérovée.
Mérovée qui est, comment dirais-je, l'ancêtre
un petit peu mythique, dit-on de Clovis.
La tribu des Mérovingiens qui sont des
Francs saliens, des Germaniques.
Les Mérovingiens ont régné
quasiment sur l'Europe,
sur ce qui deviendra l'Allemagne,
la Belgique, la Suisse, la France.
Du V au VIIIᵉ siècle.
La mère de Mérovée, déjà enceinte,
fut séduite par une bête de Neptune,
alors qu'elle se baignait dans l'océan.
Enceinte une deuxième fois, les 2 sangs se
mélangèrent,
pour donner naissance
à une nouvelle dynastie,
dont les membres étaient investis
de grands pouvoirs,
et d'une aura magique et surnaturelle,
caractéristique des Mérovingiens.
Ce pouvoir se concrétisait dans leur
chevelure qu'ils se devaient de porter longue.
Un Mérovingien aux cheveux courts
n'est plus mérovingien.
Il n'a plus d'autorité.
Les Mérovingiens, dans la famille royale,
sont très à cheval sur leur chevelure.
Parce que c'est une réminiscence de
la Bible de Samson, tout simplement.
Ils considèrent que la force,
la puissance, le respect est obtenu,
est acquis grâce à la chevelure.
On a d'ailleurs de merveilleux rois qui ont
été chevelus,
Clodion le Chevelu,
qui est surnommé le chevelu.
Quand Victor Hugo parle de Charlemagne
à la barbe fleurie,
il se trompe, parce que
Charlemagne était imberbe,
il n'avait pas un poil sur le menton
mais il avait une crinière fantastique.
Le règne de Dagobert Iᵉʳ de 629 à 639,
sera marqué par la recherche
d'un nouvel équilibre,
autour de valeurs que l'ensemble
de la population partagerait.
Dagobert est un roi qui apparaît
dans nos sources,
comme fils de Clotaire II.
C'est un roi qui monte sur le trône en 630,
et qui garde le pouvoir
pendant seulement une décennie.
C'est à dire un personnage relativement
fugace à travers l'histoire mérovingienne,
mais qui a eu pourtant
une immense postérité.
Cette mutation s'achèvera
cependant bien plus tard,
avec la naissance d'une société nouvelle.
Ce n'est pas encore la fin du monde,
mais c'est déjà la fin de la
dynastie descendante de Mérovée.
Clovis légua à ses fils un territoire
s'étendant du Rhin jusqu'aux Pyrénées.
Mieux qu'un territoire,
un regnum délégué par l'Empereur.
Cependant, le royaume fut
partagé comme un butin.
En 511, à la mort de Clovis,
les quatre fils survivants se partagent
les états de leurs pères.
On sait que chacun reçoit essentiellement,
une portion de la région centrale,
des espaces les plus riches,
le bassin parisien, les espaces rhénan
et chacun reçoit également une
frontière dangereuse à garder,
et éventuellement des zones
de conquêtes annexées.
Le partage s'appuyait sur deux
logiques héritées de Rome.
L'une administrative, qui respectait
le découpage impérial,
l'autre défensive.
Ainsi, Thierry Iᵉʳ, l'aîné,
eut la responsabilité de la région rhénane
face aux peuples germains,
et face au royaume burgonde.
Ajouté à cela, on lui remit aussi les terres
qu'il avait grandement participé à conquérir,
auprès de son père lors de la campagne
contre les Wisigoths en 507.
Les trois autres frères
héritèrent de territoires,
avec pour chacun d'entre eux
des villes fortement symboliques.
Pour Clodomir, Tours,
la cité de Saint Martin,
le soldat romain qui était
devenu l'apôtre de la Gaule.
Pour Childebert Iᵉʳ, Paris,
la ville où reposait Clovis,
et enfin pour Clotaire Iᵉʳ, le plus jeune.
Soissons et Tournai, les premières
capitales des Francs saliens en Gaule.
Plusieurs rois, mais un seul
Regnum Francorum.
Les quatre capitales étaient d'ailleurs
proches les unes des autres.
Soissons pour Clotaire.
Reims pour Thierry.
Orléans pour Clodomir.
Paris pour Childebert.
Le terme de capitale est un grand mot.
Le siège du royaume devait
être celui du palais,
mais chaque roi possédait
une dizaine de palais,
où la cour, l'administration,
les archives et le budget,
c'est à dire les trésors enfermés
dans des coffres,
séjournaient temporairement.
Tout le système était itinérant,
et les rois circulaient à l'intérieur
de leur vaste domaine,
ainsi que les hauts
fonctionnaires, les serviteurs,
et tout le personnel palatin.
Le pouvoir était donc décentralisé,
et le roi avait un besoin vital
de relais stable dans chaque cité.
La cité était une idée romaine, une ville
avec les campagnes organisées autour.
Ces intermédiaires indispensables étaient
choisis parmi les élites.
Au nord de la Loire élite franque et au sud,
grande famille gallo-romaine.
Ce personnel avait des fonctions
administratives, militaires,
judiciaires et fiscales.
Chaque responsable de cité
était appelé comtes.
Ils recevaient des terres
et la protection du roi,
en échange de ses services
et d'un serment de fidélité.
Les serments de fidélité
des guerriers à leur supérieur,
sont connus depuis le Vᵉ siècle.
C'est une création romaine.
Toutefois, les Barbares ont adopté ces
serments qui prennent des noms variables.
On parle de Truste au début
de l'époque mérovingienne,
mais on parlera plutôt de vasselage
à partir du VIIIᵉ siècle.
Cependant, dans chaque cité,
il y avait un personnage beaucoup
plus important que le comte.
L'évêque.
Il était élu en théorie par
ses pairs et par la population,
mais en pratique, bien souvent
désigné par les rois.
Aux sixième et septième siècles,
l'évêque concentre la plupart
des pouvoirs civiques,
au sein des grandes villes du monde Franc,
c'est à dire qu'il a non seulement
les pouvoirs religieux,
mais également des pouvoirs fiscaux,
éventuellement des pouvoirs militaires,
et surtout, il représente sa ville
lors de chaque grandes occasions,
notamment lors de la visite du roi.
L'unité du royaume fut d'ailleurs incarnée
pendant un temps par Clotilde,
l'épouse de Clovis,
qui dut sinon assurer une régence,
au moins influencer les décisions
de ses enfants.
Lorsque Clovis meurt en 511,
il laisse un fils ainé,
né d'un premier mariage, Thierry,
et trois fils très jeunes nés
de son union avec Clotilde.
Il semble que Clotilde ait imposé le partage
pour favoriser sa propre descendance,
et pendant près de 15 ans,
elle assure la régence,
au nom de ses trois fils les plus jeunes.
Une certaine unité aussi, quand il
s'agissait, le printemps arrivant,
d'amener les hommes au combat et d'organiser
de grandes expéditions militaires,
dans le but de consolider le trésor royal
et d'enrichir les fidèles.
La cible la plus évidente
était la riche Burgondie.
Les quatre frères affrontèrent les troupes
burgondes le 25 juin 524,
à Vézéronce près de Vienne.
Bataille qui fit non seulement la défaite
des Francs, mais aussi la mort de Clodomir,
dont la tête servit de trophée
aux soldats burgondes.
Clodomir avait déjà trois fils,
qui trouvaient refuge auprès
de la reine Clotilde.
Mais Childebert
et Clotaire s'en emparèrent.
Ils envoyèrent alors un message à Clotilde,
lui faisant comprendre que le destin
de ses petits enfants,
était entre ses mains.
Elle avait le choix entre
une épée et des ciseaux,
la mort ou la tonsure.
La femme de Clovis ne put se résigner
à ce que les fils de son fils,
perdent leurs cheveux et leurs auras,
et ne puissent ainsi accéder au trône.
Clotilde est consultée et Clotilde
répond "plutôt mort que tondu",
et donc autorise les oncles
à exécuter les neveux.
Les enfants de Clodomir
vont disparaître ainsi.
Clotaire eut le temps
d'en poignarder deux,
avant que le troisième ne prenne la fuite
avec l'aide de quelques domestiques.
Clodoald, c'était le nom
de l'enfant qui survécu,
choisit la tonsure et fuyant
les hommes et les loups,
fonda un monastère en région parisienne
et devint Saint-Cloud.
Clotaire, Childebert et Thierry,
dépecèrent le royaume
de leur frère en trois parts.
Clotilde se retira à Tours,
près du sanctuaire de Saint-Martin.
Après le sud-est, direction
le nord-est et la Thuringe,
où là aussi d'autres loups
se disputaient un trône.
La Thuringe est une région située
à l'est de l'Empire Franc,
dans la région des fleuves
de la Saale et de la Vézère,
et qui est un espace depuis longtemps,
guigné par les rois des Francs,
qui ont des contacts et qui ont des
espérances pour récupérer cette région.
Thierry et Clotaire profitèrent de l'état de
guerre civile pour envahir le royaume,
probablement en 531.
Le trésor de guerre fut partagé en deux lots,
dans celui de Clotaire, des terres
et une princesse de onze ans, Radegonde.
Clotaire Iᵉʳ est connu pour une politique
matrimoniale particulièrement dynamique.
Il a eu au moins six femmes
légitimes successives,
la plus connue d'entre elles est Radegonde,
princesse thuringienne.
Qu'il a épousé dans les années 550.
À partir de 532, de nouvelles campagnes
furent menées en Burgondie.
En 534, elles fut enfin annexées.
Les Burgondes sont des envahisseurs
venus de l'Est, de Germanie,
qui vont de leur côté,
régner sur le Sud-Est de la France
et même également sur la Suisse,
qui deviendra la Suisse romande,
et laisseront leur nom à ce qui va
devenir le royaume de Bourgogne.
Dans les années 520-530,
Le royaume Franc tente d'annexer la Burgondie,
Le royaume occupé par
le peuple des Burgondes.
À la suite d'une série de batailles
particulièrement sanglantes.
La Burgondie est annexée
certainement en 534,
lorsque le dernier roi des Burgondes
est obligé de s'enfuir,
et de laisser Lyon
aux mains des Mérovingiens.
En 537, coincée entre le Regnum Francorum
et l'Empire d'Orient,
le royaume ostrogoths, qui, en 526,
avait perdu le grand Théodoric,
cèda la Provence au regnum.
Non seulement l'unité
de la Gaule était réalisée,
à l'exception de la Septimanie
qui reste wisigothique,
Mais aussi et peut être surtout,
les fils de Clovis avaient
accès à la Méditerranée.
Ce n'était pas tout à fait l'empire, parce
qu'au-delà d'un noyau autour des 4 capitales,
l'autorité des Mérovingiens était contestée.
Tout d'abord à l'intérieur d'un cercle
incluant l'Aquitaine et la Provence,
qui avaient connu
l'occupation wisigothique,
ainsi que la Burgondie
fraîchement annexée.
Un peu plus loin à l'est,
un deuxième cercle était constitué
par les territoires périphériques,
comme la Thuringe et l'Alémanique,
qui perdit aussi son autonomie,
dans les années 530, en même temps que la
protection des Ostrogoths,
dont la puissance déclinait.
Ces contrées fédérées prirent le
nom de duché,
terme qui servait à désigner
des regroupements de comtés.
Avec la disparition de Thierry en 534,
et de ses enfants en 555,
puis celle de Childebert en 558,
Clotaire Iᵉʳ régna seul sur ce regnum
Francorum jusqu'à sa mort en 561.
Comme son père avant lui,
le plus jeune des fils de Clovis,
était le maître de l'Occident,
Clotaire Iᵉʳ, fils de Clovis,
est le premier roi après son père,
à réunifier le monde Franc,
même s'il le réunifie
de façon extrêmement courte,
entre 558 et 561, date de sa mort
et date d'un nouveau partage.
L'un des fils de Clotaire, Chramn.
C'était une première fois allié
avec son oncle Childebert,
afin de défaire son père
et de s'approprier son royaume.
Le fils vaincu obtint le pardon du père.
Après la mort de Childebert, Chramn récidiva.
Une nouvelle fois vaincue,
Clotaire ne refit pas la même erreur.
Il enferma Chramn avec femme
et enfants dans une cabane de pêcheur,
qu'il fit brûler.
Les mœurs de Clotaire Iᵉʳ peuvent
effectivement heurter certaines sensibilités.
Il heurta assurément celle de la jeune
captive de onze ans qu'il avait reçu en lot,
lors de l'annexion de la Thuringe en 531.
Radegonde.
Clotaire et ses guerriers avaient
martyrisé son peuple et massacré sa famille.
Il força pourtant celle-ci
à l'épouser en 538.
Radegonde était sa troisième épouse.
Elle ne plia jamais
aux exigences de son époux.
Lors de réception, Radegonde apparaissait
sobrement vêtue d'une tunique blanche.
Son humilité chrétienne tranchait
avec le rang qu'elle devait tenir.
L'union dura pourtant
une quinzaine d'années.
Clotaire ne voulant pas s'avouer vaincu,
face à celle qui défiait son autorité.
Il le fut cependant, et Radegonde,
retrouvant sa liberté,
fonda un monastère dédié
à la Vierge à Poitiers en 555.
Radegonde, une fois séparée de son mari,
fonde un grand monastère à Poitiers.
C'est le monastère Sainte-Croix de Poitiers,
le premier grand monastère de femmes d'Occident.
A la mort de Clotaire Iᵉʳ, en 561,
la Gaule fut de nouveau partagée
entre ses quatre fils restants.
L'austrasie au royaume de Reims
revenait à Sigebert Iᵉʳ.
La Burgondie au royaume d'Orléans,
fut donnée à Gontran.
Le Royaume de Paris pour Charibert et le
petit royaume de Soissons pour Chilpéric.
En 567, Charibert disparut sans fils,
son royaume,
celui de Paris fut donc répartis
en trois, et en premier lieu,
Paris elle-même, dont les revenus fiscaux
furent divisés en trois parts égales.
Autre conséquence majeure
du nouveau morcellement,
Chilpéric changeait de statut en obtenant
des domaines qui rapportaient,
et allaient lui permettre
de concurrencer ses frères,
en créant une troisième entité en face de
l'Austrasie et de la Burgondie, la Neustrie.
La Neustrie est un territoire
du royaume de France,
mais de la partie Nord-Ouest
du Royaume de France,
c'est à dire une grande
partie du royaume.
La capitale à ce moment là,
je crois, était Soissons,
Neustrie qui va couvrir
également la Normandie...
C'était un territoire assez
important que cette Neustrie,
contrairement à l'Austrasie, qui elle,
était à l'est de la France,
l'Austrasie qui a d'ailleurs été
créée pour un des fils de Clovis,
et dont la capitale sera Reims
pendant quelques temps.
Sigebert lui, régnait sur
la partie la plus exposée du Regnum,
et alors qu'il était occupé
à défendre ses frontières,
Chilpéric l'attaqua.
Sigebert, finalement vainqueur,
pardonna à son frère
et fit preuve de clémence.
En 566, le roi des Wisigoths accorda
la main de sa fille cadette, Brunehaut,
aux plus puissants des Mérovingiens,
Sigebert.
Ce fut une cérémonie fastueuse,
à l'image de sa magnificence.
De plus, à 15 ou 16 ans à peine,
la mariée était cultivée,
gracieuse et très belle.
Cette union est le premier acte
d'une tragédie.
A l'époque des petits fils de Clovis,
on voit apparaître une série
de reines extrêmement dynamiques.
La plus célèbre est Brunehaut, princesse
Wisigothique ayant épousé Sigebert Iᵉʳ,
fils de Clotaire Iᵉʳ.
Brunehaut va se maintenir
au pouvoir pendant 40 ans,
comme épouse, mère, grand-mère,
puis arrière grand-mère du roi régnant,
assurant, pratiquement à chaque fois,
la régence du royaume.
Jaloux, Chilpéric demanda alors au
roi des Wisigoths,
la main de sa fille aînée, Galswinthe.
Ce dernier accepta.
Une double alliance avec les Francs,
valait mieux qu'une.
La tradition voulait que le lendemain
de la nuit de noces,
l'époux qui avait reçu
la virginité de sa promise,
lui fasse en échange un don qu'on appelait
don du matin ou Morgengabe.
Chilpéric consentit à lui donner
un tiers de son territoire.
Le mariage qui eut lieu en 567
devait lui fournir un héritier.
Au bout de quelques mois, le ventre
de la princesse Wisigoth restait plat,
et Chilpéric retourna dans les bras
d'une ancienne épouse, Frédégonde.
Or, si Galswinthe retournais en Espagne,
et l'emmènerait avec elle,
le Morgengabe.
Mais le père de celle-ci trépassa
et sans plus craindre sa vengeance,
Chilpéric fit étrangler la sœur
de Brunehaut pendant son sommeil.
Une nuit de 568.
Il se remaria alors rapidement avec
Frédégonde et à partir de là,
pour des générations d'historiens,
ce fût la haine
entre Frédégonde et Brunehaut,
qui allait mettre à feu
et à sang le royaume des Francs.
Le début d'une guerre civile
qui allait durer 45 ans.
Frédégonde, femme de Chilpéric Iᵉʳ,
petit fils de Clovis,
est la grande ennemie de Brunehaut.
Non par haine personnelle, les deux reines ne
se sont jamais rencontrées de leur vie,
simplement parce que Brunehaut favorise le
personnage de ses fils et petit-fils,
alors que Frédégonde tente d'imposer
son propre descendant, Clotaire II,
comme maître de l'ensemble du royaume Franc.
C'est la période où les Francs
se battaient et s'entre battaient.
Les Frédéric, Brunehaut ou Brunehilde,
tout le monde s'entredéchirer. C'est
une période assez sanglante de notre histoire,
qu'a connue Frédégonde.
Le prix du sang était alors
codifié dans la loi salique.
Un tribunal présidé par Gontran,
légitima la guerre que Sigebert
était en droit de déclarer à Chilpéric.
Afin qu'il puisse récupérer
une partie du royaume de celui-là,
en paiement de l'offense faite à son épouse
Brunehaut, la sœur de Galswinthe.
Gontran recevrait une partie des territoires
conquis pour son rôle d'arbitre,
tandis que Sigebert était tout
près de la victoire finale,
Chilpéric, retranché dans la ville
de Tournai, envoya deux esclaves,
assassiner son frère.
Le siège fut immédiatement levé.
Les Austrasiens repartirent chez eux
avec le fils du roi défunt, Childebert II,
que Brunehaut avait
eu le temps de lui donner.
Cette humiliation réclamait
une vengeance divine.
Des catastrophes naturelles ravagèrent
alors le royaume de Neustrie.
La même année, une épidémie de dysenterie
tua les deux fils,
de Frédégonde et de Chilpéric.
Et tandis que la Neustrie
s'affaiblissait,
Brunehaut devint une véritable
reine mère en Austrasie,
à partir de 584.
Quelques mois plus tard,
Chilpéric fut poignardé
par un de ses serviteurs.
Avant de mourir, il avait
eu un nouveau fils avec Frédégonde,
le futur Clotaire II.
Pour gouverner, les Mérovingiens avaient
besoin du ralliement des élites locales.
Les grands monopolisait comtés et évêchés,
ainsi que les charges publiques
à l'intérieur du palais.
Brunehaut fit tout pour
limiter leur pouvoir.
Pour elle, l'ordre prévalait
et le modèle restait l'empire.
L'autorité impériale était encore forte.
Mais une autre référence se fit
de plus en plus pressante à Rome.
Le pape, que les Mérovingiens
avaient oublié.
Brunehaut avait compris l'importance
de l'évêque de Rome,
et il se trouvait qu'elle était
contemporaine de Grégoire le Grand,
et du pape en 590.
Celui-ci était décidé à réformer l'Eglise.
Trop de charges spirituelles étaient
accaparées par des individus,
qui n'étaient pas véritablement
des hommes d'Eglise.
Ils étaient mariés
et préoccupés davantage,
par des enjeux matériels
que par le salut des âmes.
Grégoire voulait apporter à l'Occident,
ce qui lui manquait.
Une organisation sociale en accord avec
la philosophie que véhiculait l'Église.
Le seuil du Moyen Âge
sera bientôt franchi.
Grégoire le Grand, pape de l'an 600,
est sans doute le personnage,
qui a sauvé la papauté, cette papauté
qui était extrêmement faible,
aux V et VIᵉ siècle et qui va
être relevée par ce personnage,
qui accepte soudainement
de ne plus percevoir le pape,
comme le grand évêque de l'Empire romain,
mais comme le patriarche d'Occident,
cet Occident qu'il va chercher à convertir,
notamment en lançant de grandes
missions vers le monde anglo-saxon.
Bruno était loin d'être populaire auprès
des grands d'Austrasie et de Burgondie,
que Childebert II, son fils,
récupéra à la mort de Gontran en 593.
Il mourut en 596.
À la mort de son dernier petit-fils,
Thierry II en 613,
et du fils de celui-ci, dernier
héritier, Sigebert II la même année,
des grands d'Austrasie se
rapprochèrent de Clotaire II.
Retenons deux noms :
Arnoul de Metz et Pépin de Landen.
Le fils du premier
épousa la fille du second.
De cette union naquit Pépin de Herstal,
père de Charles Martel.
Grâce notamment à ces deux conspirateurs,
Brunehaut fut capturée.
Torturée pendant trois jours.
Elle fut ensuite exhibée nue,
entre les bosses d'un chameau,
au milieu des insultes.
Puis on l'attacha par les pieds
sur le dos d'un cheval.
Le reste du corps traînant
le long des pattes arrière.
Le cheval put alors partir au galop.
Clovis avait délimité un périmètre.
On attendait que quelqu'un
creuse les fondations.
Le fils de Clotaire II,
allait pouvoir le faire
maintenant que Brunehaut,
entre la mort de sa sœur et la sienne,
avait levé les dernières hypothèques
au prix de son sang.
Il s'appelait Dagobert.
Roi unique du Regnum,
Clotaire II voulait un état central
puissant comme Brunehaut.
Il convoqua à Paris tous les évêques,
et  tous les seigneurs laïcs
du Regnum, en 614.
Ceux-ci lui cédèrent
les trésors de Brunehaut,
mais il dut maintenir les trois entités
indépendantes avec pour chacune,
un délégué responsable de leur gestion,
qui reprit l'appellation déjà ancienne,
de maire du Palais.
A partir des années 580 apparaît
au palais Mérovingiens,
un personnage de haut
fonctionnaire bien connu,
qui est le personnage du maire du Palais.
Il s'agit avant tout d'un intendant,
qui assure le bon fonctionnement
des institutions.
On se rend compte qu'à partir
des années 610, ce maire du palais,
devient le premier personnage
de l'Etat mérovingien,
au point qu'en cas de régence,
c'est lui qui assure la quasi
totalité des pouvoirs.
Il y avait maintenant un roi
et trois maires.
La guerre civile avait
affaibli le pouvoir royal,
tandis que les trois composantes
se construisaient une identité propre,
renforcée par les grands.
Dagobert naquit vers 604
et jusqu'en 613,
il fut bercé par les événements
de la fin de cette guerre civile.
Adolescent, Dagobert appris
son futur métier de roi,
à l'école du Palais, institution
dont Clotaire semble être à l'initiative.
Il rentra en contact
avec un cercle de fidèles,
nourri par le souverain,
et potentiellement davantage
préoccupé par le bien public,
que par l'ambition personnelle.
Assermenté, il recevait une formation
juridique de haut niveau,
afin de participer à la politique
de centralisation du Regnum,
qu'on peut commencer à appeler Francie.
Le premier de ces esprits
éclairés était Éloi.
Il avait 16 ans de plus que Dagobert.
Orfèvre de formation,
il était le maître royal des monnaies.
Le second s'appelait Ouen,
né en 600, repéré par Éloi.
Il intégra cette élite grâce à ses
compétences exceptionnelles.
Un troisième se nommait Amand.
C'était l'homme d'Eglise de ce
noyau dur qui allait contribuer,
au rétablissement de l'autorité royale.
Grâce à eux, Dagobert se lança
à la reconquête du pouvoir.
Le roi Dagobert est surtout connu
pour avoir de très grands ministres.
Le plus célèbre est le trésorier
du palais, Saint-Éloi.
Il y a eu également
d'autres personnages éminents,
comme Saint-Ouen, qui va travailler
comme haut fonctionnaire à sa cour.
Ces personnages nous ont laissé
une importante correspondance,
grâce à laquelle on peut reconstituer
la vie de cour à l'époque du roi Dagobert.
La rivalité entre Neustrie
et Austrasie n'avait pas disparu.
Cette dernière réclamait
la présence d'un roi.
En 623, Dagobert fut choisi pour
représenter son père, Clotaire II,
dans le pays de Pépin de Landen,
où Pépin Iᵉʳ,
nommé à vie, maire du palais d'Austrasie.
En tant que délégué du roi,
il était le seul à pouvoir faire la loi.
Dagobert s'appuya
sur cette période de paix,
pour uniformiser
et rationaliser la justice.
Un calendrier fut tout d'abord défini
afin de fixer régulièrement des audiences.
En cela, Dagobert est véritablement
le précurseur de Saint-Louis.
Tout comme lui et avant lui, Dagobert
rend la justice où qu'il se trouve.
A l'époque de Dagobert,
la justice de modèle romain,
a tendance à moins bien
fonctionner qu'autrefois.
Dans la mesure où les grandes aristocraties locales,
assurent le traitement
de la plupart des procès.
Dagobert, pour réinstaurer
une autorité monarchique sur la justice,
se déplace énormément à travers le
royaume et part tantôt en Burgondie,
tantôt en Austrasie pour essayer d'imposer,
un traitement public,
étatique, monarchique de la justice,
en imposant très souvent
la peine de mort.
Chaque nouvelle audience
débouche sur un nouveau décret.
La réforme judiciaire est instantanée.
Les lois deviennent la loi.
A la mort de Clotaire II, en 629,
Dagobert prit en main la Francie.
Malgré l'existence d'un frère
discret et peu instruit,
qui n'avait jamais suscité beaucoup
d'espoir de la part de son père.
Nommé tout de même vice roi d'Aquitaine,
il mourut en 632.
Dagobert s'installa rapidement
en région parisienne.
Une équipe gouvernementale s'était structurée
à partir de l'école du Palais,
et Paris devint un centre administratif.
La diminution du trésor royal rendait
difficile la politique ambitieuse,
de ces hauts fonctionnaires.
Il était donc indispensable
de récupérer des biens,
appartenant à la Couronne qui avaient
été généreusement distribués,
pendant la guerre civile.
Face aux protestations,
la raison d'Etat fut invoquée.
Convaincu ou non, l'église s'inclina.
Tout était en place
pour la grande réforme,
que voulait mettre en place Dagobert
et ses amis d'enfance.
Éloi, le grand argentier du royaume,
pouvait être considéré
comme un premier ministre.
Proche des humbles, Éloi
en quête de justice fiscale,
précisait les devoirs des grands en
échange des honneurs qu'on leur attribuait.
Tout en protégeant les petites gens,
consolidait le pouvoir central.
Éloi de Noyon était
un personnage qui était...
Comment dirais-je, une manière de
ciseleur, d'orfèvre, de bijoutier,
et que le roi Dagobert Iᵉʳ
appréciait énormément,
à tel point qu'il va en faire
son ministre des Finances.
Et c'est d'ailleurs le fameux Saint-Éloi
qui figurera dans la chanson que,
au XIXᵉ siècle, on chantera le bon
Saint-Éloi avec le cher Dagobert.
Ouen référendaire et garde du Sceaux,
généralisera en Neustrie et en Bourgogne,
l'action que Dagobert
avait entreprise en Austrasie,
en uniformisant la loi.
La justice est maintenant
la même pour tous,
sans abus immoraux, mais conformes
aux valeurs d'une société chrétienne,
qui se voulait nationale.
Tout vient du roi,
tout est garanti par le roi.
Sur la lancée de la réforme
du pape Grégoire le Grand,
Amand, l'aumônier de la cour,
assainit le clergé.
Les hommes d'Eglise furent
de moins en moins de faux dévots.
Il inaugura chez
les Slaves et les Basques,
une nouvelle forme d'évangélisation
en représentant l'autorité royale de Dagobert.
L'adhésion à la religion du roi,
était aussi l'intégration au nouveau
système mis en place en Francie.
Le prestige du roi amena Héraclius,
empereur d'Orient,
à contracter un traité de paix éternel.
Restaient dans le domaine militaire,
deux priorités.
Tout d'abord, pacifier les deux peuples,
qui n'avaient jamais été totalement
soumis par les Francs,
Basques et Bretons.
Ce qui fut fait.
Les premiers par les armes en 635,
les derniers par la négociation.
Ensuite, renforcer la frontière
orientale, ce qui fut fait.
Saxons, Thuringiens,
Alamans et Bavarois,
Toute une Germanie potentielle,
plus que jamais fédérée à un royaume,
dont le centre de gravité
se situait beaucoup plus à l'est,
que les cités de Neustrie.
La paix du roi était solidement
installée en Francie,
ce qui permet à l'économie de s'épanouir.
La production augmentait,
les échanges et les déplacements
se multiplier,
entre Méditerranée et Mer du Nord,
avec le Bassin parisien
comme relais privilégié.
Au début du VIIᵉ siècle, on voit un
basculement de l'économie mérovingienne,
qui jusque là était tourné de façon
très classique vers la Méditerranée.
Au début du VIIᵉ siècle, l'espace
dynamique devient la mer du Nord.
Et très rapidement, les rois mérovingiens,
installent de grands ports
sur la mer du Nord,
imposent des droits de douane,
et tournent tous leur intérêt commercial,
vers le monde anglo saxon, notamment
en passant de grands traités commerciaux.
L'antiquité se diluait dans ce qui allait
devenir la France médiévale.
La base de cette vitalité était
l'influence grandissante,
des grands domaines agricoles,
contrôlés par l'aristocratie et l'Église.
Le VIIᵉ siècle fut le temps des évêques.
Ils ne participaient pas seulement au
développement de l'agriculture,
bâtisseur et restaurateur
des édifices du culte,
ils relançaient l'artisanat.
Propriétaires terriens,
les évêques tenaient également la ville,
l'hospice, l'école,
une partie de l'administration
judiciaire et fiscale.
Le réseau des évêques s'étendait
à présent à celui des monastères,
sous l'impulsion notamment de Saint Benoît.
Sa règle s'appuyait sur
trois principes fondamentaux :
Obéissance, pauvreté et chasteté.
L'ordre des Bénédictins fut soutenu
par Grégoire le Grand.
Contemporain du pape réformateur.
Colomban, débarqué d'Irlande,
fit pratiquer dans ses monastères,
une discipline encore plus stricte,
où les mauvaises intentions
ne trouvaient leur rémission,
que par le châtiment corporel.
Le Haut Moyen Âge voit la multiplication,
des grandes fondations monastiques,
sous la direction
de personnages charismatiques.
Saint Benoît en Italie
au VIᵉ siècle puis,
Saint-Colomban au début du VIIᵉ siècle
dans le monde Franc.
Il s'agit de personnalités issues
de la très haute aristocratie généralement,
qui obtiennent des terres, soit des
terres personnelles, soit des terres du roi,
sur lesquelles ils fondent des monastères
en imposant une règle.
Eloi contribua à alimenter
ce réseau de monastères.
Benoît et Colomban furent les
piliers du monachisme occidental,
et participèrent activement
à la réforme de l'Église,
qui permit l'émergence
de la chrétienté occidentale,
telle qu'elle allait
être pendant 1000 ans.
Il y a deux saints emblématiques,
qui ont été protecteurs
des rois de France.
Il y a eu en premier, à l'époque
des Mérovingiens, Saint Martin.
D'ailleurs, les Mérovingiens
se déplaçaient souvent,
avec la relique de la cape
de Saint Martin,
dans leur cortège.
Et puis ensuite,
il y a aussi Saint Denis.
Saint Denis prend une grande importance,
notamment à l'époque des Capétiens.
Donc il est protecteur de la France.
Et c'est vrai que les Capétiens,
dès avant Hugues Capet,
Étaient abbé laïc de Saint Martin,
mais aussi de Saint-Denis.
En 250, Denis était devenu
le premier évêque de Paris.
Il fut décapité par les Romains
sur le mont des Martyrs.
On raconte qu'il prit alors sa tête
et marcha ainsi en direction du nord.
Saint Denis était l'évêque de Paris.
C'est un Saint bien connu
puisqu'il a accompli un miracle.
C'est un Saint céphalophore,
c'est à dire qu'il a marché,
en portant sa tête dans ses mains.
C'est un chrétien, naturellement,
qui va, à cette époque là encore,
connaître la torture des païens.
Alors, torture dramatique,
parce qu'on va le flageller,
mais il va survivre,
on va le griller, mais il va survivre.
Tout ça à Paris, du côté de Montmartre.
On va lui couper la tête.
Il la ramasse, il la prend,
il traverse la capitale,
la fameuse rue des Martyrs
qui porte encore ce nom aujourd'hui.
Et il s'en va jusqu'à Saint-Denis,
où il dit c'est ici que
je vais me faire enterrer.
Du temps de Clovis,
Sainte Geneviève lui fit
construire une basilique,
à l'endroit où il se serait arrêté,
et participa au développement de son culte.
Sainte Geneviève est une petite paysanne,
née à Nanterre et qui va devenir,
la patronne de Paris
depuis que la légende,
lui a attribué le sauvetage
de ce qui allait devenir la capitale,
qui ne l'était pas encore
devant les Huns,
terribles menés par Attila.
Dagobert favorisa à son tour
ce lieu de pèlerinage,
occupé par une congrégation sous
l'autorité de l'évêque de Paris.
Il lui donna des terres et surtout
le droit d'organiser des foires.
C'était une grande première qu'un
roi accorde ce privilège,
à un centre religieux.
On sait qu'il y a une foire
importante à Saint-Denis,
et que cette foire génère
des revenus extrêmement profitables,
pour le trésor mérovingien.
Ce qui implique que le roi Dagobert,
comme son père et comme ses descendants,
va s'intéresser beaucoup
à cette abbatiale.
Le bon roi était victime depuis
son enfance de crises d entérite,
qui lui provoquait des maux
de ventre particulièrement douloureux.
En janvier 639, une nouvelle
alerte très violente,
l'affaiblit considérablement.
Sentant sa mort prochaine,
il demanda à être transporté près
du tombeau de Saint Denis,
où il mourut le 19 janvier.
Il fut le premier roi à être
enseveli dans cette basilique,
qui allait devenir abbatiale et nécropole,
de tous ceux qui se succéderont
sur le trône de France.
Le bon roi Dagobert est devenu
une légende parce qu'après lui,
commence l'ère des rois fainéants.
Dagobert avait eu deux fils
de deux épouses différentes.
Sigebert III, qui avait dix ans en 639,
hérita de l'Austrasie,
et Clovis II, cinq ans, de la Neustrie
et de la Burgondie.
L'unité de la Francie n'était plus,
et le bel mais fragile équilibre obtenu
par Dagobert et ses fidèles serviteurs,
laissa la place de nouveau au chaos.
Les rois enfants de Dagobert allaient
bien sûr perdre la réalité du pouvoir,
au profit des grands.
Ils inaugurèrent le règne des rois fainéants.
Les Mérovingiens restent des rois relativement
puissants jusqu'à la fin du VIIᵉ siècle.
Même au début du VIIIᵉ siècle, le roi
mérovingien est assez bien assis sur le trône,
pour condamner son propre maire du palais
pour malversations financières.
Toutefois, à partir des années 710,
la plupart des rois sont extrêmement jeunes,
et les maires du palais prennent
une importance telle,
que le roi est condamné à l'inaction,
ce qui a entraîné
la légende des rois fainéants.
Ils ne font pas grand chose. Et pourquoi ?
Parce que d'abord, ils règnent
très hâtivement, très brièvement,
et les pouvoirs sont détenus, à cette
époque là, par le maire du Palais,
comme le sera Charles Martel.
Ce sont les maires du palais, qui dirigent.
Eux n'ont rien à faire, donc ils sont oisifs.
Au XIXᵉ siècle, sous la troisième
République, sous Jules Ferry,
On va les caricaturer, on les imaginera
dans des lourds chars couverts de coussins,
traînés lentement par des bœufs
cheminant de ci de là.
Sans véritable autorité.
Ils ne faisaient rien ou faisaient néant.
Les rois fainéants restaient sur le trône,
parce qu'on ne pouvait pas supprimer les
descendants de Mérovée du jour au lendemain.
La légitimité de cette dynastie
était ancrée dans les mœurs.
Dès 687, les Pippinides, membres d'une
dynastie de la noblesse d'Austrasie,
permirent à Pépin II de Herstal,
de réunir entre ses mains les mairies
d'Austrasie et de Neustrie.
La famille de Pépin et Arnoul s'étaient
enrichis pendant que les rois se ruinaient.
Elle s'appuyait sur des guerriers
qui leur avaient juré fidélité,
par un serment d'allégeance.
En 751, avec l'aval du pape,
le fils de Charles Martel,
Pépin le Bref, coupa la longue chevelure du
dernier descendant de Mérovée, Childéric III,
Le dernier héritier de Clovis,
finit ses jour dans un monastère.
Les Mérovingiens étant dans une phase de perte
de puissance depuis le début du VIIIᵉ siècle,
Pépin le Bref considère dans les années 740
qu'il est temps désormais,
de changer la dynastie royale.
Il envoie une lettre au Pape,
pour obtenir l'autorisation
de déposer le dernier Mérovingiens.
La réponse lui parvient,
l'autorisant à éliminer ce Mérovingien,
et en 751,
Pépin se fait couronné Roi à Soissons,
Roi des Francs.
Désormais, on parlera
de dynastie carolingienne.
Acclamé roi par les guerriers,
les évêques et les grandes familles,
Pépin donna plus de crédit
à sa nouvelle couronne,
en se faisant sacrer par le pape
dans l'abbatiale de Saint-Denis.
Restait à asseoir cette légitimité
sur le long terme.
De fausses généalogies fleurirent alors.
Au IXᵉ siècle, on inventa
des filles à Dagobert,
afin qu'elles puissent
épouser des Pippinides.
Dans certains documents, Arnoul de Metz,
d'au moins 25 ans son aîné,
devient le petit neveu de Dagobert.
Le Saint-Empire germanique
ressentit le même besoin.
Le partage que Dagobert avait
effectué entre ses deux fils,
préfigurait déjà ce qui allait arriver.
Une Austrasie qui se retrouverait
dans le premier Empire Germain,
et une Neustrie qui était le noyau
du futur royaume de France.
Vers 830 fut rédigé
une biographie de Dagobert,
à l'abbaye de Saint-Denis, sous le règne
de Louis le Pieux, fils de Charlemagne.
De nombreux événements firent
leur apparition dans cette chronique.
Ainsi lors d'une partie
de chasse près de Paris,
tandis que le jeune prince
poursuivait avec ses chiens serres,
l'animal traqué trouva refuge
dans une chapelle dédiée à Saint Denis,
et les chiens n'osèrent pas pénétrer
dans le lieu sacré.
Plus tard, Dagobert s'était montré insolent
avec l'un des fidèles de son père,
et comme celui-ci le menaçait,
il revint dans cette chapelle
dans laquelle il s'endormit,
et, en rêve,
contracta un marché avec le martyr.
Le Saint lui promit sa protection
si en échange,
Dagobert s'engageait à honorer sa mémoire.
La réconciliation avec le Père
eut bien lieu.
Dagobert favorisa la renommée
et la gloire de Saint-Denis.
À partir du IXᵉ siècle
et pendant près de 200 ans,
Dagobert va poursuivre
ses donations à Saint-Denis.
Les moines de l'abbaye vont
produire 18 contrefaçons de diplômes,
attribués à Dagobert.
Les fausses donations permettent
à Saint-Denis de s'enrichir,
et de devenir ce qu'elle va devenir,
la nécropole des rois de France.
Tous ces faux soulignent le crédit,
la légitimité,
la référence intouchable qu'incarne
Dagobert dans la mémoire populaire.
La basilique de Saint-Denis est
effectivement un monument emblématique,
de la royauté française,
puisque beaucoup de rois
sont enterrés dans ce monument.
On parle souvent du roi Dagobert
comme fondateur de l'abbaye.
En réalité, il semblerait qu'une communauté
religieuse existait déjà avant le roi Dagobert,
mais par contre, il a été un des
grands bienfaiteurs de l'abbaye,
et c'est le premier roi
à se faire enterrer,
dans cette basilique à côté de Saint Denis.
Premier Roi enterré à Saint-Denis,
Dagobert est à l'origine de la
mystique qu'entoure l'abbaye.
Concrétisation du message politique
et spirituel de la monarchie française.
Quelques Mérovingiens seront
enterrés à cet endroit,
à partir de Louis VI, tous les rois
de France seront enterrés à Saint-Denis.
Jusqu'à la Révolution, évidemment,
et jusqu'à Charles X.
Quand le système féodal va morceler le
pouvoir au point que le roi de France,
n'est qu'un seigneur pas plus
puissant que bien d'autres,
la royauté s'appuiera sur Saint-Denis,
en faisant de la basilique le berceau
de l'art gothique au XIIᵉ siècle.
Le concepteur du projet, l'Abbé Suger,
complètent la propagande architecturale
en réclamant l'héritage temporel de Dagobert.
Le roi qui règne et son descendant.
Le roi Dagobert a une mémoire
attachée à Saint-Denis,
qui conservait un élément, un signe,
qui est le trône de Dagobert,
trône qui va servir
à plusieurs rois de France,
et qui va servir pour la dernière
fois pour Napoléon Iᵉʳ,
qui s'assoit dessus le jour
de l'entrevue de Boulogne.
Saint-louis poursuivit le long processus
de christianisation de la fonction royale,
en étant canonisé en 1297.
Saint Louis qui fit construire
à Dagobert, vers 1250,
un mausolée.
C'est sous son règne que furent
rédigés à Saint-Denis,
les grandes chroniques qui font
la part belle au bon roi Dagobert.
Architecture, sculpture, écriture.
Dagobert pénètre pour toujours
dans la mémoire nationale en formation.
Les moines de Saint-Denis ont vu
relayer leur devoir de mémoire,
envers leurs bienfaiteurs,
par les prêtres de toutes
les paroisses de France qui,
pendant des siècles,
au cours de leurs sermons,
vont régulièrement raviver
la flamme Dagobert.
Le bon roi est une synthèse
d'humanité faite roi.
Il personnifie les valeurs chrétiennes
de justice, de sagesse et d'humilité,
tout autant que les faiblesses de l'homme.
Monogame en série,
il contracta cinq unions légitimes,
et accumula les concubines.
Ce bon vivant avait la réputation
de bien se tenir à table malgré sa maladie.
Ce côté paillard le rapprochait du peuple
plus que de l'excommunication.
Sa distraction légendaire fut
mise en chanson au XVIIIᵉ siècle.
Il est ici utilisé
comme caricature d'un roi,
qui allait bientôt perdre la tête.
Populaire grâce à ses actes politiques
tout autant qu'à son mode de vie,
il est le modèle du bon roi,
comme le fut près de 1000 ans après,
Henri IV.
Cependant, sa fermeté face
aux grands et sa quête de justice,
n'était peut-être que la
manifestation d'une stratégie,
qui avait pour objectif, avant tout,
le renforcement de l'autorité royale.
Dagobert a servi de garde fou
au futur roi qui devront méditer,
sur la leçon du bienfaiteur
de Saint-Denis.
Ils apprendront dès le plus
jeune âge le projet divin,
leur tuteur étant bien souvent choisi
parmi les membres de l'église.
Dans les périodes de chaos,
ceux qui, de nouveau,
voudront restaurer l'ordre,
s'appuieront sur son héritage.
Si l'arbre mérovingien vacilla
rapidement après sa mort,
Dagobert avait enraciné profondément
sur un terrain religieux favorable,
le ferment de la nation française.
Un gouvernement solide,
une justice équitable,
une hiérarchie qui organise un territoire
à partir de Paris, capitale unitaire,
et surtout des principes élaborés
de son vivant où à titre posthume.
A la mort de Dagobert,
5 générations après Clovis,
les descendants de Mérovée
deviennent des pantins.
Clotaire Iᵉʳ fut à la tête d'un
royaume de la taille d'un empire,
qui ne fut d'ailleurs dépassé que par
2 empereurs dans l'histoire de France,
Charlemagne et Napoléon.
Le demi siècle suivant fut
marqué par deux femmes,
Brunehaut et Radegonde,
qui montrent la voie à suivre.
L'une sur le plan temporel,
l'autre sur le plan spirituel.
Conseillé par des esprits éclairés,
Dagobert transforma en héritage le travail
de restauration débuté par son père.
Le royaume n'est plus un trésor
que l'on se partage.
Et si la Francie n'est pas
encore une patrie,
Dagobert, lui, est bien un patriarche.
Quant à l'héritage des Mérovingiens,
la fin de leur monde marque
le début d'une seconde étape,
dans la construction d'un autre,
qu'on appelle le Moyen Age.